so it's great to be back in Kalamazoo at
the last time I was here they took me to
the Blues Festival which it I love the
Blues but they need to figure out some
problems with the festival I don't think
I don't like the party anywhere where
you can't just give somebody money and
they give you back a beer you know what
I mean I stood in line for an hour my
mouth is dry I want a beer I love beer I
know they're selling beer people are
walking away with the front of the line
they've got beer that's how I figured
the whole thing out I get up there I
give the guy my money goes we don't take
money here what do you take coupons
ha
poopins where do I get a coupon
you see that line over there it takes
forever I stood in that line for an hour
I got to show them a driver's license
birth certificate fill out a form they
mail that away send me back some coupons
what are you doing Ron I'm waiting on
UPS sir there's a good chance I'll have
a beer by Thursday I'm partying like a
Kennedy right now
I was game to add a hundred bucks cash
on me about a hundred bucks worth of
coupons and then some guys it took me
there asked me if I wanted to go to a
topless club and I didn't want to go I
just ended up going cuz you guys back me
up on this you've seen one woman naked
do you want to see the rest of neck
there could be an old biker chick you
know they're going to hang down to here
you'll see Matt teen easy yeah dude
all right that's enough rolling back up
things that make you go and then closing
time came around and the tabs came out
and I found out the titty bar don't
accept them cooping a guy Taco Bell told
me to kiss his ass I'll give you $40
where the coupons for a burrito with
cheese it's all I've got
it's a coupon so I saw something comes
close to truth in advertising the De
Beers people are almost saying what they
really mean because the old De Beers
slogan was diamonds are forever then
they changed it to this year take her
breath away the new slogan is diamonds
render her speechless why don't they
just go ahead and say it diamonds
that'll shut her up
for a minute so man I was just in Miami
[ __ ] I don't I was a couple years ago so
I didn't kiss just would not be the word
but I was working there with Fox when
Hurricane George hit the keys I just
thought this is kind of funny they
evacuated the keys and everybody left
except for I've been through two
hurricanes I was in hurricane Carla when
I was a kid in Houston and I was really
excited during hurricane time you know
because it's out there in the Gulf and
it's dangerous and I was like this is
cool till [ __ ] started hitting our house
I was like [ __ ] this but anyway they
evacuated the keys and everybody leaves
except for one guy who's going to stay
there and tie himself to a tree on the
beach to prove a point and the point was
he said that at 53 years of age he was
in good enough physical condition to
withstand the wind and the rain from a
forestry hurricane all right let me
explain something to you it isn't that
the wind is blowing
it's what the wind is blowing
if you get hit with a Volvo it doesn't
really matter how many sit-ups you did
that morning
and if you have a yield sign in your
spleen joggin don't come into play
I can run 25 miles without stopping
you're bleeding
[ __ ] ma'am last time I was here I had
somebody broke into my truck and spelled
my radio thank you whoever you were got
to drive back to Texas listen the sound
to win 449 hours I went to the
insurance-company I was filling out
these forms and I got to the part on the
form where it says what kind of radio
was it that's all the guy didn't
remember it he said mr. white if you can
remember what kind of radio was will
know how much money to give you
that's some good news right there I
thought of a real expensive sounding
brand then I wrote it down and he knew I
would live mr. white I don't believe
Rolex makes a radio it was a clock radio
brat to check premium boy they love it
when you call them premium boy next time
you see your agent call him premium boy
you'll get a chuckle